une 29e édition qui comme chaque année
donne envie d'aller voir la suivante des
photos à couper le souffle où l'on peut
presque toucher ces animaux qui en
retour ne laisse pas indifférent elles
sont touchantes évidemment aussi
c'est le côté graphique
je trouve les noirs en arrière-plan sont
magnifiques ils sont d'une densité
antarctique et après les quand on
regarde la photo de très très près la
neige et la glace est sculpté par le
vent et on a dégradé de blanc qui sont
magnifiques sur du noir et avec toutes
les teintes de bleu de la fameuse
piscine est ce qui donne l'échelle c'est
les phoques qui sont là avec en plus un
apport de technologies pour obtenir des
photos que le photographe ne peut pas
faire derrière moi il ya des photos de
piégeage électronique composa n'apparaît
dans la nature on laisse un mois et le
photographier créé son cadre et il
attend ils espèrent pendant dix mois
d'avoir un individu d'une espèce
particulière
la centaine de photos exposées est une
sélection de 45 mille clichés venu
candidaté en provenance de 95 pays à
voir jusqu'au 24 février 2019 au muséum
de bourges